now the new president of guinea-bissau
there he is
Umar Oh Sissoko am Baloo has promised to
improve the situation for the people in
the country a place which is marked by
extreme poverty and corruption so what
is life like for ordinary people in the
West African nation well DW spoke to a
19 year old teenager Zito Urbino he is
trying to make ends meet by working on a
tourist boat he told us about his hopes
for the future and also what in his
opinion definitely has to change for
things to get better in one of the
world's poorest nations for the tourists
on these speedboats the islands of
Guinea Bissau in West Africa offer a
taste of paradise for residents like 19
year-old z2 el vino they provide the
income that allows him and his family to
survive I'm a sailors assistant which
means I take people in the boat to
Bissau and bring them back or I take
them to other islands they wish to visit
I help carry things to the boat
I also check the weather it's a big
responsibility with the clients to see
if it's worth taking the risk to sail or
not
but z2 faces many challenges in his life
he's supporting at least six other
relatives with this job I was born into
a very poor family my father does not
have work and neither does my mother
with five siblings and right now I'm the
head of the family he uses the money he
earns here to pay his education and also
that of his siblings but he says going
to school is not something you can take
for granted in a country as poor and as
dysfunctional as Guinea Bissau karaoke
I wish things would be better and that
we would have more home because in our
politics things don't go well at all for
instance we start classes and all of a
sudden it's strike strike strike and
then we lose the school year and then
the next year the same thing happens but
he's determined to forge ahead with his
plans to make a better life for himself
and his family although he says it would
be easier if politicians radically
changed their behavior their skins and
their losses they should start thinking
about others and not just themselves
they should start working for all
Ghanaians when it comes to the direction
the country should be going cito has a
clear message for the president
he he must improve the schools and offer
children new schools different than the
ones we have now to give the children a
motivation for the future Zito says his
dream is to finish his studies and to
get a job in tourism and then one day be
his own boss